you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 28
from the beginner to chess master
playlist a progressive series of videos
that continues to slowly develop the
topic in this one is positional in
nature it is in great contrast to the
previous videos topic from this playlist
where I focused on tactics this one is
concerned with moments of tension
moments where you can capture moments
where you can chop
I'm not sure when this started but I'll
sometimes say chop instead of capture
anyhow my simple piece of advice to you
is to stop before you chop and the
reason why I'm drawing attention to
these moments in the game is because
this is where you may be giving your
opponent without even realizing it an
inch and we don't want to do that we
want to try our best if at all possible
to come out ahead in these capture
recapture sequences
the examples I share with you are
primarily focused on even ish positions
white is slightly better maybe black is
slightly better
what we can observe in the game quite
often are changes in the assessment
depending on the decisions we make in
moments of tension by focusing on this
area of the game it's going to help me
to simply open up a positional dialog
I'll be able to share some of the
factors that go into well some of the
positional factors that help me know who
is really the side who is benefiting
with the capture recapture sequence
here's the thing there are plenty of
cases where you are rewarded by being
the one who recaptures there are plenty
of cases where you are rewarded by being
the one who is just a little patient in
initiating the capture we want to try
our best to come out ahead if at all
possible in those moments
one final note before I dive into
a ton of examples is the phrase even
exchanged when you hear that what comes
to mind for you even exchange what's
that night for night Brooke for rook
pawn for pawn right for some of you it
may be helpful to no longer include that
in your vocabulary
the phrase even exchange for some of you
may be helpful
why do I think this well I think it will
immediately force you to think more
critically in the game it's gonna force
you to see a rook for rook exchange and
question you know what there are no even
extreme someone's benefiting right to
have this there are no even exchanges in
chess mentality may be helpful for some
of you I know it was for me in preparing
for this video and it's something that
I've been focusing on for quite some
time this was not always a part of my
thinking in the game but I'd say over
the past year
it has impacted my play being attentive
to these moments in the game it may seem
insignificant to some of you these
examples I share it's like just a tiny
shift and the evaluation of me
never too early regardless of where you
are in your playing strength it's never
too early to not give your opponent an
inch okay so I think that's all the
intro I wanted to give I think we could
go right after these examples here this
one here being the first so I think in
nearly every example I throw your way
every position I'll have some arrow and
this one here is indicating that it is
white to move and you could treat this
arrow as quickly asking the question
would you chop it's white to move here
would you chop would you take the black
Queen and feel free to you know pause
the video and come up with an answer
would you chop yes or no
if yes have one reason at least one
reason why you would do that if no why
not and on top of that well what might
be something better okay so let's go
right here white to move what would you
do you know would you chop excuse me
hopefully no um it's not a good idea to
initiate the exchange here because black
is taking a rook that's on a closed file
to an open file and before you know it
this rook is going to be attacking this
pawn and good luck white trying to
defend this right the rook can very
easily now and now let's just say the
King moves over the white rook and now
very easily find itself you know having
to defend upon you can move this guy
here and then this and we have a case of
what a very active rook versus what is
known as a passive ruckus strictly
defensive piece so there's no benefit in
initiating exchange here what would be
better okay this rook that was on a1
wasn't doing anything let's get it doing
something it's not an open file okay
let's continue same story here team
white would you chop okay here we go
not a good idea to initiate the exchange
and for similar reasons
just broderick that was on a closed
falchion open file and before you know
it this rook will be targeting these
pawns over here what would have been
better
well what about this get this rook to
half open file and at the same time
you're paving the way to allow the king
to enter in this simplified ending right
the king is going to need to play a part
in this endgame okay this next example
middle game or no opening position
would you chop
no not a good idea to take the Queen
here because you're simply helping black
to recapture and develop a piece what
would be better well let's get on with
development you develop and say well you
capture me that way I can slightly
improve my night it's in the keys 16
squares and I'll often like to describe
my pieces in this way I like to describe
the nights as well this is now a
fourth-ranked night instead of what was
a third-ranked
night usually better to have a
fourth-ranked night than a third-ranked
night anyhow moving on
like to move here would you chop the
night okay here we go now
two rare that all
have examples where the bishop is in you
know has the opportunity to take the
night most examples would be you know
pawn for pawn Knight for Knight rook for
meaning for Queen Bishop for Bishop but
not this imbalanced exchange just a few
concerning this exchange would you take
the knight hopefully no there is no
benefit first of all the bishops are
slightly more valuable than the knight
and the other thing is that you would
simply be helping black to recapture and
improve a piece and I think of the two
recaptures with the piece
this is the better one because the night
is now a from blacks perspective a
third-ranked night it's in this key 16
keys 16 squares of the board
no benefit in initiating this exchange
something better back off h4 f4 okay
another thing you know when I'm
considering this capture one of the
first things that crosses my mind is
you know I look at my opponents the
piece that's going to recapture and I
think to myself is it is it recapturing
and moving forward
if the answer that is yes that's
automatically you know that gives me
pause to maybe reconsider now I'm not
saying that it is always going to be a
positive if your opponent is able to
recapture and have that peace move
forward but generally speaking if your
opponent is recapturing in that piece is
moving forward I think you'll find very
often that that is an improvement for
the piece okay let's have a look at
another example
this one here where I just inserted a
couple different moves so in that last
example the bishop would you chop on
this square would you voluntarily
capture the night the answer was no
there but what about a situation where
the bishop is under fire you're still
gonna take the night hand you know get
that move back is it important in this
position for white to let's say have
that next move or is it more important
to maintain the bishop the answer here
more important to maintain the bishop
its bishop is more valuable than the
knight back off to h4 back off to f4
if this bishop if this Knight was pinned
to the Queen I would be that much more
inclined to go to h4 instead of f4 I
think I would still go to maybe h4 here
but the main point is that capturing the
knight here is not a wise choice that
recaptures and loves its position next
example all right what about this one
now would you chop okay here we go
it is a move
and the reason why I'm putting this one
up right after those last two examples
of these is because black with this
capture at least get something in return
and at those last two examples black was
simply recapturing and you know that
recapturing piece was improved it was
helped a tiny bit
with this sequence black can at least
say AHA white now has doubled pawns not
always a bad thing
white has double pawns and drawing on
some other terms we lured learned from
this playlist white now has several
holes on the queenside c3 as a whole c4
as a whole
a3 a4 something that black can maybe
take advantage of at some point black
gets a little something in return for
this bishop for Knight exchange in this
position okay
why cats let me put me back on let me
just be clear white get something the
way has you know a bishop black has a
knight white has some deficiencies on
the Queen side some weakens squares so
there's a little bit of a trade-off
there okay let's have a look at another
example this one here would you chop
see five takes d4
here we go no not a good idea to
initiate this exchange because white is
able to recapture with the SI pom taking
towards the center is usually a good
idea ponds that are
in the center tend to be more valuable
pawns also pawns tend to increase in
value with every rank every step forward
and on top of this exchange this
recapture you'll note that white is
under bling at these ponds which is
usually good news to have your ponds
straightened out now undone so not a
wise choice to do that
would be a better move what about d6
supporting this guy being in a position
to meet a capture with the recapture
and now all the sudden what would have
double isolated ponds and that's that's
usually something to that usually is a
great deficiency in a position oh one
other note regarding the ponds is that
sometimes I like to say the following to
myself you know if black is capturing
like this white is recapturing what two
ponds have been exchanged just no black
pawn on c5 has been exchanged for the
white pond on c3 I'll sometimes like to
run this through my internal dialogue
I'll say black has just exchanged it's
not just pawn for pawn right we're
seeing we're trying to see beyond the
material we're trying to look at the
positional factors well what has just
happened black has exchanged off its
fourth rank pawn right from blacks
perspective fourth rank for whites third
rank pawn hmm is it a fourth ringing
pawn a little bit more valuable than a
third rank pawn now
I say this you have to be a little bit
careful but in this situation here
that's not the primary thing that I look
into I look at it as white is under
blowing the pawns but I just want to
throw it out there I don't just see the
Knights as let's say a fourth ranked
Knight and a third ranked night or
whatever I look at the pawns this way as
well
apply a bit of a ranking system and it's
it's helpful for me maybe it'll be
helpful for you okay let's have a look
at another one
what about this one here would you chop
on c6 okay here we go it is a good idea
for white to take the night first of all
it's under fire a couple times
clean is hitting it Knight is hitting it
it's a good idea to take the night and
even though black is taking towards the
center and you may say well the pond I
thought you said the ponds that are a
little bit closer to the center more
valuable in general yes at the same time
here and no the ponds could be a bit
tricky at the same time by capturing on
c6 like this white is benefitting
somewhat because the black ponds are no
longer a pond duo which is a great
strength they are now split now isolated
and the squares directly in front of
these ponds are now wholes
maybe something white can take advantage
of one day it is a wise choice for white
to initiate the exchange short story
here let's have a look at another one
multiple in
senses of tension light to move what
would you do here would you take the
knight on c6 first the pawn on d5 first
or none of the above maybe something
else once more feel free to pause the
video here we go
okay it is a good idea to initiate the
exchange here as white
you want to be careful the order you do
it however best is to capture on d5
after the recapture - then take on c6
and we're observing something similar to
the last position with this order of
captures White has been successful in
splitting up the black Queen side pawns
notice if the order was changed if you
take the knight first
then upon this guy
is at the moment isolated can simply
join his friends on the kingside this is
now what we can describe for black one
nice pond island of five the fewer the
pond Islands the better in general the
ponds are able to help one another
defend one another if need be the order
matters best is to take on defy first
and then see six ok let's have a look at
another one I'll be sharing several
examples like this positions that spring
about right out of the opening this is a
very familiar position its kondu out
here and well would you chop on d4 with
the poem feel free to pause the video
here we go yes it is a good idea to
capture on d4 with the pond important
too
pandu o's are a great strength and it is
important to address upon duo this is
something I have touched on in a
previous video I believe it was the what
to do in a chess opening video number
three I think in this series so it goes
way back pawn duos are a great strength
you like to either break them up
challenge them in this position here
important to break up the pawn duo even
though white is able to recapture and
improve this Knight and it's a fourth
ranked night instead of a third ranked
Knight it's more important to make sure
the pawn duo is broken up if I'm to
provide a reason for why you would want
to do this well in this particular case
what other your other options as black
if you don't capture on d4 with the pawn
do you play f6 no this Knight cringes
took away its favorite square what about
this move here well for one this move is
saying well I am okay with going on
castled because if white wants to like
can initiate the following exchanges and
one way or the other eventually can
force black to take with the D pawn and
what we have Queen takes Queen White has
gained some with this sequence because
the black King is now
uncle and may be subject to attack could
be a bit uncomfortable for black
what am I getting up at this moment in
the game there isn't really a great way
to lend support to the e5 pawn the
timing is not right it's important for
black to break up the pawn duo in this
case this is one of my favorite two
positions right here I'll actually I
like this position so much not really I
like this position so much that I will
be bring it up a little bit later let's
continue
what about a position like this so it is
a bit more evolved from the position we
just saw there right out of the opening
what about here what is a pawn duo here
last example we initiated the capture
should black do that here no notice in
this position there isn't this drawback
like in the last position where black if
they tried to support the pawn on e5
would end up one day going on castled
black is already castled black has
support for the e5 pawn and does well in
this position to maintain the tension
not initiate this exchange one quick
quick reason to maintain the tension is
because well what do you what would you
think is being accomplished by capturing
like this White's going to recapture the
pawn and they're still going to be
present a pawn duo for white and on top
of that this Knight is a little bit this
Knight is a little happier because it
now has access to the c3 square black
does well to maintain the tension right
initiating this another way to view it
is that the black pawn that was on e5
has been exchanged for the one on c3 a
fourth rank pawn has been exchanged for
a third rank pawn white does well to
maintain the tension here do something
else
might that's something else being maybe
rook to e8 getting it to a file where
maybe at some point this exchange does
happen in the rook can be brought to
life here on the e4 upon sometimes there
may be this concern wealth
what if what if the pawn goes here this
is getting a little bit more involved
this is a pawn that will eventually come
under fire I really don't want to go too
much further down this path eventually
you will see a move like c6 and you know
this this lesser Frank pawn will be soon
getting rid of this d5 pawn it'll be a
pond that cannot be maintained for white
anyhow the short story without getting
too involved in each of these examples
is that black does well to maintain the
tension here let's have a look at
another one ah favorite example quick
story here I have I observed a
tournament where it was a Scholastic
section and
two games right next to each other
the first five moves were identical this
same position came about in both of the
games and a poor decision was made in
both games the same poor decision was
made in both games this is a position
I've already shared in a previous video
I believe it was the element of time
video anyhow quick pop quiz same one
would you chop okay hopefully no in this
case Knight takes Knight allows white to
recapture and the Queen is improved help
the white queen develop so what would be
better well what would be better here is
to get on with the development so I'll
move like Bishop c5 is what comes to
mind and a lot of players wouldn't maybe
do this because there's this fear of
having the pawns doubled but this isn't
it's more important not to help the
queen establish a wonderful position in
the center than to worry about these
doubled pawns these guys can't really be
targeted in this position there's still
a fine group of pawns again it's more
important to not help the white queen
establish this wonderful position in the
center okay there are other moves
besides Bishop c5 Queen to f6 which you
really have to be a bit cautious about a
move like that because you're taking the
way this Knights favorite square anyhow
the idea here apply some pressure to
this piece and say you know what no you
capture me you capture me and I'm gonna
recapture and maybe you could at one
point demonstrate that this pawn is
actually useful being a tiny bit closer
to the center maybe now it's around to
support a d5 advance okay let's have a
look at another one this one here so
we're just what one move in to this
position would you chop okay here we go
it's an okay decision to do this in it's
it's one of the best moves the best move
I could just say and it may seem a bit
odd to do that with some of the
reasoning I've already shared well if
you capture here isn't black able to
recapture isn't this an improvement well
yes it is but unlike the previous
position right unlike this previous
position where once you capture in the
Queen recaptures you'll notice there
isn't a great black move that will scare
the white queen will attack the white
queen a productive move if you're
thinking well can't black oh here you
missed a video earlier in this series
because you're creating holes this is
not a developing move okay
there isn't a productive move that black
has in this case to attack the Queen but
in this position it's a different story
alright we initiate this exchange
yes we help the black queen but at the
same time we're going to gain this
valuable developing move with an attack
against the black queen and we go on
from here we can now establish a pawn on
d4 and eventually what we have is this
battle where White has a strong 4th
ranked pawn versus what is in all
likelihood going to be a 3rd ranked pawn
for black the thing here is that it is
ok it is best in this case to just go
ahead take the pawn yes I help the Queen
but I get a tempo back I get this I gain
some time back by developing with an
attack against the Queen ok let's have a
look at another one uh-huh another pawn
duo black to move would you chop okay
yes important to do this if you are not
taking on d4 with the pawn
downside will be well you might get run
over if you just bring out another night
this night I'll be kicked this night
could be kicked next night could be
kicked right away where is he gonna go
back home he five words it's not gonna
go back home this is now how you play
okay Pandu oh it's a strength needs to
be addressed it is a good idea to
capture even though white is recapturing
and slightly improving more important to
break up that Pandu oh okay next example
same position what about now you broke
up the Pandu already do you take the
night no you get on with development you
don't want to help improve the Queen
similar position is uh you know a couple
positions back where you know the only
difference is in this one the C pawn is
absent the other one it was the e pawn
okay you wouldn't want to you only take
to a certain point you break up the pawn
duo and then okay I'm not gonna take
again this is where I'm giving some
pause I'm not chopping on d4 I'm just
gonna help out the Queen something
better what about Knight f6 here's a
little trick I might as well throw this
in there are you afraid of this
shouldn't be got this little maneuver
something I fell for in a tournament
game it was painful anyhow short story
don't take this Knight you are only
helping white next what about here okay
you probably have the idea now pawn
duels are strong let's break them up
can take probably a good idea to do that
because what else are you gonna do is
black gonna go here this bishops not
gonna be too happy with you wants to be
able to one day go outside of the pawn
chain you're gonna go here you have to
deal with the knight being scared away
does he know where he belongs
okay important to break up the pawn duo
first and then get on with some
development something like this we go on
okay I don't want to go any further you
get the idea break up the pawn duo's not
all the time
what about here would you chop okay here
we go
yes with the palm even though the night
is improved and then you get on with
some development put pressure on this
guy and we go from here next example
what about here I just want to show you
with this one that you have different
options you're playing as white here you
don't have to capture you can push you
can also support this pawn now like this
gets in the way the night and probably
not this either because eventually this
night we'll be able to develop with an
attack against the bishop a couple of
different ways you can do a couple
different ways you can support the pawn
on e4 with the Knight c3 or d2 if you're
going to c3 you have to deal with a pin
that is not easily broken if you go to
d2 you can break the pin like this and
rely upon your knight as a defender
anyhow I don't want to get too deep into
these things but
pandu Oh in this case
I like too many times look at the
tension between the pons
and say to myself which of these two
ponds has more options in this position
it's white the white pond looking at the
legal moves right you can capture it can
push has two options whereas the black
pond has only one option
it can only capture sometimes it's a
good idea to maintain the tension in
this case if you're the side here
playing with the pond duo
keep your options open maybe support the
pump anyhow I think that is something of
value related to the ponds the ones that
have more options it's not much it's
only one more option than black but it
is something and that something has
value okay you have different options
here defend the pond maybe capture maybe
push ok let's have a look at another one
what about here it's not the best move
to initiate the exchange here you could
see that move this is a common right out
of the opening position there's
different moves to make Knight f3 is a
fine move I just want to highlight with
this one that if you're taking and a
black is recapturing with upon that this
bishop has been helped so I know I'm
drawing a lot of attention to just the
the ponds or the pieces that are
recapturing but let's have a look at
what other pieces are influenced when we
go forward with this capture recapture
sequence this Bishop now will have if
white is capturing this Bishop will now
have
four new options right not saying
hopefully we're not going to h3 but okay
one of these two is looking pretty nice
anyhow what other pieces are influenced
by the capture recapture sequence I
believe black is helped just a tiny bit
if white is initiating this exchange
something better
maybe Knight to f3 Knight to c6
okay maintain the tension in other words
as white here I think is a good idea
let's have a look at another one oh okay
so this is similar pawn structure wise
right we have this similar tension but
it is evolved a bit and it is black to
move I don't know why I am mistaken to
have that arrow up right now it is black
to move in this position and I just want
to highlight when you know sometimes you
know the timing of moves comes into play
when is maybe a good time to capture on
d5 suppose in this position black says
you know what I can't just keep waiting
for white to take on this square and
then have this door open so I'm just
gonna open up a door somewhere else I'm
gonna prepare to fee and cut on my
bishop get it on the longest diagonal
maybe at this point I would think a bit
more about capturing on d5 only after
black has invested to move to open up a
noob or excuse me a new door for the
bishop you see the little
little little tricks that you can play
on your opponent hope that's not a trick
but just having some patience right I
said that in the intro to this video
having just a little bit of patience
with this guy right here on c4 is you
know maybe buying yourself a move maybe
only after b6 does yka
okay now I'm okay with opening this door
at least I forced you to to make a b6
move to open up another door okay timing
of moves can be buying you moves okay
this one here a light to move is it a
good idea to shop on e5 no right now the
black Queen does not like being on e7 i
should say the bishop doesn't like that
the queen is on e7 the bishop wants to
move so black and castle this is an
inconvenience for black it's important
to recognize that if you're taking the
knight you're helping the queen to
slightly improve a couple ranks and the
bishop is ready to roll somewhere what
would be better
how about put pressure on the knight and
say no you take me Knight takes Knight
oh thank you I just get to recapture and
prove my Queen develop my queen and who
knows maybe I Castle queenside the point
here and I had a good idea to take the
knight
what about developing and forcing black
to take me okay let's have a look at
another one okay this one here is from
one of my games so it's not out of the
opening in game phase so would you chop
on e7 okay here we go not a good idea to
chop on e7 taking on East
seven is helping the Queen and this rook
isn't gonna be able to enter so easily
can't join in the fun it is best to just
quickly recognize you know first of all
if you take black is recapturing the
Queen is slightly improved I believe in
the game it was instinctual for me to
just not take and just go here it's not
always the case like this but in this
position I believe that that was the
case Rick to a7 turns out to be a real
killer and white white is gonna go on to
win this one it's a big problem here
with the bishop just to point out that
if Bishop takes Bishop the knight
recaptures and now there's an accident
that is bound to happen we start to see
as I pointed out in the previous video
the white pieces are now all of a sudden
intersecting on f7 and there isn't a
great defense there you go here and then
you realize well there's also the pin on
top of it all a pin intersection square
okay that's a massive fork and it brings
about with just some attention in this
case to not even helping your opponent a
tiny bit
rookies seven much better a winning move
I guess one other variation just for fun
is that if the bishop is defended you
can take like that and then go here and
this is going to win some material for
white okay
main point maintain the tension in this
case as white don't take the bishop
apply pressure to that Pete to that
Bishop force maybe black to take you and
improve one of your pieces okay another
example this one here would you chop on
c5
okay here we go not a good idea to take
care
because black can recapture and develop
a piece what might be better applying
some pressure to c5 so a developing move
back to basics development apply
pressure to this point and if black is
taking you your recapturing and slightly
improving your knight if Knight takes
here your recapturing with I think
probably the bishop actually if you're
going with the clean black hand develop
with a punch but this is this is the way
forward to increase the pressure on the
c5 pawn however indirect it is know that
well if black takes you you're gonna
slightly improve we'd certainly don't
want to be taking like this and helping
black to improve okay another example
what about this one
would you chop okay here we go it is a
good idea to chop even though black is
able to recapture and develop and put
you in a pin doing something other than
that well the knight really doesn't want
to have to move it may seem like you can
take this but there's these tricks Queen
could go to h4 the King is all of a
sudden running for his life this is
winning for black
the reason why I'm sharing this example
is because at first glance you may say
to yourself well
taking like this my opponent is helped
on the recapture and well you have to
think beyond that you have to also see
well after I take like this my rook is
improved and at the same time maybe I
don't want to move my knight from f3
this is one of the better squares an
important square in this case stop-in
Queen to h4 ok we can sometimes help our
opponent and help ourself alright the
bishop is helped the rook is helped the
knight gets to maintain its position
here it's important for why in this case
to initiate the capture let's have a
look at another one
okay would you chop on e4 okay here we
go not a good idea to take on e4 because
the knight is able to reap to recapture
and improve by a couple ranks and throw
a punch and the Queen even now has
access to a nice square on f6 what would
be better
well white can react and apply pressure
to e form can go to d2 so this is it's
getting a little bit more involved to be
sure you may think well why not move
forward this Knight can now apply more
pressure here and maybe now be forcing
you to take like this and once you don't
want to allow this it may be the case
you don't want to allow at one point
Knight takes e4 hitting the Queen like
this one of the better moves is in fact
to apply pressure to this point and say
no you take me you take me and help my
bishop to improve there might be a
little bit of a battle going on see this
with you know stronger the player is I
think you'll see these these battles go
on in a game this little fight over not
wanting to give an inch in fact towards
the end of this video I'll be sharing a
couple a couple
Gamze to a certain extent we'll find in
the games where the tension is just
present for an extended period of time
neither player wants to give an inch so
this could be one example here the
bishop place to this square
why can maybe keep that tension still in
play pawn to b3 you know or maybe even
at this point it may be quite alright to
take on e4 because eventually white is
not having to budge with the Queen and
can carry on with developing even though
there is a threat in this particular
case it is not an inconvenience to
address it you can continue to develop
have your King there to defend play
continues point here is that it is not
best to invite this night forward with a
punch something else is better 92 is it
okay another one what about here
would you chop once more feel free to
pause the video okay here we go not a
good idea to take on b6
and this is something important to know
this is not a liability for black having
these doubled be pawns this is a fine
group a fine
pawn island black benefits some because
this rook is brought to life and the
same can be said you know if let's say
there's a dummy move made white would be
benefiting some if black initiates to
see this exchange the rook is brought to
life maybe even at some point this rook
can have some nice lateral influence in
the position but the point here is that
it is beneficial it is more important
let's say to have an open file for the
rook like this than to worry of oh my
pawns are doubled there is value in
having an open file for a rook didn't
even have to move its on its home square
and it's activated okay let's have a
look at another one okay this one here
white to move would you chop okay here
we go hopefully no because of this
improvement rook from a closed file to
an open file okay you probably got that
one's judging by the well I already went
through a couple examples earlier I
think the first couple examples were
with the rooks or Queens intention okay
what would be better well here's
something better
Bishop to a6 put pressure on that rook
and say no you take me you take me and
help my rook improve so just a little
bit of patience there applying a little
bit of pressure on that rook force you
to take me I'm going to improve at the
end of the day in my rook will one day
become very active targeting upon an a7
maybe the pawn on e6 okay you get the
idea
what about this example it's not a well
this was a little bit different my
question to you with this example is
well first of all there's an attack here
against b7 how to defend b7 feel free to
pause the video how would you defend b7
okay important to note that Queen b6 is
a fine move once more if Queen takes
Queen even though we can take with the
night it is still better in this case to
take with the pond and have some rook
activity taking with the knight c5 not
always a good idea to release this
tension to you know no longer have
pressure on d5 but c5 can be played in
this case with an attack against the
night it's not best to have the night on
b6
capturing recapturing like this with the
pawn is very good for like this this is
this is the best way to recapture this
is the best way to defend against b7 and
there should be no fear of these doubled
pawns this is it's very nice to have
this activity for the rook now there's a
reason why I'm sharing this particular
example and it's something I'm pretty
sure most experienced players can relate
to well we've probably all been there
where we make the move b6 and we can
start to see how this position can
well it starts to resemble the last
example I shared with you where this
square is available for the bishop
and what file is completely opened
eventually we can we can expect there be
we can expect a battle over the see file
and to give up the a six square to the
bishop now playing b6 has given white
this pep playing b6 has given white
access to a bishop a6 move this is going
to be big trouble for black one day you
can very easily see white take advantage
of this this isn't the only reason why
b6 is bad this is a reason why b6 is bad
this is something I have experienced and
again I imagine many others who have
enough experience with the game have
experienced this can be painful
important to be able to meet this Queen
to b3 move very often with Queen to b6
because the move b6 there can be some
problems one day okay let's have a look
at another one uh-huh
this is another I guess pop quiz here it
is black to move and the question I have
for you is how to defend this threat
feel free to I'll give you two options
be six or a six what would you do
okay the best way to defend is with b6
because if you play a six similar to
that last example this Bishop can go
here and eventually you can have to do
something you're not comfortable with
taking help this rook to improve and one
day it will become very active and fast
and well what else are you gonna do
you're just gonna move off of the file
and the rook is still gonna sweep in one
way or the other
best move is to play b6 that way you can
still fight for control over the D file
one other example related to this last
this last example this one here so let
me just be clear this position right
here is one I just shared how to defend
against a7 what about this position so
the only thing I've done is eliminate
the rooks so just for fun
I guess how do you defend a7 now
the rooks absent a six is a six let me
just say would be my choice there's no
battle going on over the D file it would
not bother me if the bishop played to b6
next it's not hitting anything and I
would prefer to keep my pawns out of the
line of fire off of the dark squares in
this case anyhow just something that
crossed my mind here in preparing for
the video it's interesting maybe for
some of you to note that in this
position it's important to play b6 with
the rooks on the board and where there
is still fight over the D file but with
the position absent of rooks a6 is
better moving on what about here would
you chop okay hopefully no if you take
the rook we've been here before this rip
becomes very active and soon yeah it
seems like black is you're gonna be
really close to winning upon splitting
the uprights hitting a double pawns here
a fork in other words from b2 so what
would be better
now that we know probably by now taking
the rook is just not a good idea
what would be better well here's
something that's better for b3 saying
what you take me and thank you my recs
are helped are extremely my pawns are
helped just a little bit
they're back together their group
they're a duo black would probably do
well to play a mimicking game and say no
you take me okay we would go from here
the main point here don't initiate the
exchange what would be a little bit
better
rook to b3 okay let's move on okay this
one here would you chop okay hopefully
we get the idea No
because this rook is very active what
would be better the Rick would recapture
go from close to open what would be
better this would be better
that's a nice hole in the blacks
position in blacks position and white is
basically saying well if you take me now
I can recapture with the pond one way or
the other normally you would go towards
the center again ponds being more
valuable in the center most of the time
in both cases the main point is that
white now acquires a connected past pawn
and this is value this is valuable in
the game to have a connected past upon
should it eventually be the case the
rooks are exchanged this should be very
good news for white to have a connected
past pawn a reason to actually in this
position not take towards the center is
because there is now this how to say it
there is now a quick way for black to
create a passed pawn I'm not saying
black should do this right away but
there is an outside past pawn sometimes
in the endgame positions the pawns that
are closer to the edge can be more
valuable than the center pawns and
that's that has to do with one day
forcing the opponent's king to have to
run a little bit farther you know has go
towards the yet towards the edge of the
board to stop that pond whereas normally
we would like to say some you would like
to stay somewhere towards the center
again in general capturing towards the
center would be the way in this
particular case taking away from the
center not allowing black to create a
passed pawn on the edge of the board
to the edge close to the rook file is a
is a bit of a better choice but the main
point here not to get too too deep into
it is to not initiate the exchange and
to take a step up and be in a position
to recapture and in this case create a
connected past pawn should black take
and it may be one of the better moves
actually for black to go ahead and
initiate the exchange otherwise why it's
going to control I have two very active
rooks might be best for black to do but
again main point this is better than
capturing okay what about here black to
move would you chop okay here we go okay
by now you know it's not a good idea to
take like this this rook is able to
recapture and improve so what would be
better this is where a important
decision here can ultimately result in
black having an active rook versus a
passive Rock a better move than
capturing would be to step up
so you take me and now I'll be able to
one day have complete control over the
only open file and the fewer the files
that are open in the position the more
valuable they are to control right only
one file open here to have control over
that only open file that's very
important in this case for black so
instead of capturing on D one little
rook lift in this case rook d7 or even
rook to ya rook d6 or rip to d7 would be
a better choice for white and now I like
this one because you're you're in a spot
to not only go here but maybe even
triple up and put a ton of pressure on
the d1 square okay
rip d6 far better than initiating that
capture let's have a look at another one
oh this is one where I was playing as
black
and I just want to share this with you
because I made an error and yeah let's
let's see if we could benefit from my
error here I knew well here was my
thinking
in this game I thought to myself well if
I just take the Queen takes I'm helping
the Queen even though she's backing up
she's now on an open file so I said to
myself no I'm gonna go here and say
after you take me my queen isn't
improved but my opponent replied I think
it was in the game very quickly my
opponent said yeah I know what you're up
to c4 so what did I what did I fail to
do here in playing Rick to d5 well one
of the things at least
I didn't question the stability of this
move when I played Rick d5 I didn't I
didn't think to myself can it be hit by
a pawn or a night I believe during the
game I was I also considered this but
saw night the night could also play here
and put pressure on my rook but for some
reason I wasn't seeing this move so it's
something to take into account right if
you want to make these kind of moves
where you maintain the tension and say
no you take me and help me improve you
might want to question the stability of
that that move rook d5 in this case is
gifting white a valuable c4 move this
these guys would eventually like to get
rolling against these two white has a
majority of pawns on the Queen side
three versus two and eventually you know
in time a passed pawn can be produced
okay short story here Rick d5 was not a
good move because of the move c4 and if
I back to Huff he'll win here light
would do well to play Knight to e5
hitting my rook okay moving on
yeah so yeah yeah not that I really
needed to share that example but I'm I'm
certainly no expert when it comes to III
I have my own mistakes that I continue
to make in these in these moments in the
game but yeah hopefully we're benefiting
from my my error there okay black to
move here would you chop okay hopefully
no there's no benefit the white rook
improves what would be better than
capturing the rook so in the position
two ago I pointed out that you know a
rook stepping up would be a better idea
what about here is that a good idea the
answer to that is no because white will
initiate the exchange and now go here
and eventually take control over the
only open file hmm what would be better
than well something productive would be
creating a flight square
G 6 H 6 not going to get into the
details behind which one of these two is
better but it's important not to
initiate that exchange our excuse me
it's it's important not to step up like
this in this case because white will
take control over this open file and now
I don't know how this rook is getting
active anytime soon
best in this case to maintain the
tension not initiate the exchange and
get on with something that is productive
and productive in this case would be a
flight square such as gg7
all major pieces still on board we don't
want to have any fear of back rank mates
okay we in this case maintain the
tension what about this position would
you chop okay here we go in this case
yes this is a good idea in this case
even though the Queen is recapturing end
on this open file it is different
because white is in position to go here
with an attack on the Queen and seize
control over the only open file see how
that just worked there right one
position ago this one right here
light is in a position to recapture with
the rook
but this one here if you can force that
Queen to be the one that's on that open
file and there's still two major pieces
around like this eventually this can
translate into white having full control
over this only open file and if I'm to
take it further why is this so important
well we start to look at these positions
right where should the Queen be captured
what black is recapturing and huh
active versus passive rook what do you
do you go here this guy gets targeted
you go here in this rook cries you get
the idea okay it is a good idea to
initiate the exchange in this position
and I'll also add rook d6 is in fact in
okay move as well
rook d6 if takes the Queen recaptures
and if this we go here and we're gonna
eventually have control over the open
file it's gonna be up to white you know
do you want the Queen's on in this
ending or not either way this guy is
going to be passive
so you have two options is what I'm
getting at you could initiate the
exchange or even play route to d6 in
this case moving on okay what about this
position would you chop on d3 okay here
we go
yes it's a good idea to chop even though
the Queen is recapturing and improving
something I would not want to have to do
for one as black is recapture with the
rook right you're not going to be able
to castle then and another thing is if
you develop the knight
I don't really don't want to be in a
position to have to demote my knight
like this the best thing to do is to
simply initiate this capture whoops yeah
initiate the capture even though the
Queen is improved we initiate the
capture and get on with development it
would be a bit of an inconvenience if
white is capturing here we're gonna have
to demote one of our pieces in the
recapture okay next example what about
the this one would you chop okay in this
position yes you would
let's take note that black is actually
generating a threat against the bishop
and so there isn't really a great way to
let's say support this pawn if let's say
the Queen was still on the home square I
may consider stepping up to d2 where I
could then defend the bishop but in this
particular case the Queen has already
developed I don't know that this is such
a great improvement or even good at all
as something else that white asked to
worry of is a key defender being knocked
out of the bishop
best thing to do here is to initiate the
exchange it's a bit of an inconvenience
to do anything else to back off I mean
there isn't a great square for the
bishop to back off to even though the
Queen has helped a tiny bit there really
wasn't a better choice for white in that
case okay let's have a look at another
one this one here would you chop okay
yes it is a good idea for black to
capture on f3 and at first glance it may
appear that well why are you doing this
the knight is able to go from Rank 1 to
now rank 3 isn't white helped well yes
but at the same time this Bishop is
under fire is there a great great way to
defend the bishop is it a good idea to
maintain the tension not really so for
one if you think rook to b8 not really
useful to do this is black I mean for
one I don't know if the rook is really
any better placed on b7 than it was on
f8 I don't foresee the B file opening up
and in fact there may even be a train of
thought that goes something like this
the rook is unprotected on b7 and
tactically vulnerable because of that
and from f8 it isn't unprotected it's
best to initiate the exchange Bishop
takes Bishop in this case even though
the knight is improving on the recapture
one other note is that if you're
considering Knight to b6 so that the
queen is in a position to recapture I
don't know that this is really a great
improvement for the night the night on
b6 is easily negated or offset by the
pawn on b3 there really isn't a great
forward move for this Knight all the
forward moves are under control
it's probably best to keep the night
right where it is initiating the
exchange is best in this case
okay let's have a look at another one
what about this one would you chop on
any four okay it is a good idea to take
the night on a forum the night is after
all generating a threat against the
bishop so you really don't want to
waste time in backing up the bishop
right here you want to address the
threat that the knight is generating
against the bishop even though it's
helping the queen to improve we want to
kind of get that move back and now we
can put it to use and get on with some
development after the Queen is
recapturing we can think about like
Bishop to e6 okay the point here it is
okay it is a good idea to initiate the
exchange in this case even though the
Queen is slightly improved let's have a
look at another one
so black to move would you chop okay yes
it is a good idea to take on a3 because
even though the rook is recapturing and
moving forward that is a demotion of the
rook
how many options is a half from a 1 1 2
3 well after this it has four options
from this square but when it's on a
three only has two and another factor
its unprotected on a three so I said
this earlier on that in general you know
if the piece is recapturing and moving
forward that's normally you know I
normally see that as a an improvement
for that piece well not here
that's a demotion even though it's
moving forward on the recapture next
example what about this one here black
to move would you chop okay hopefully no
no because you're inviting this Queen
who is now a sixth rank clean very deep
in Black's house the King now has no
moves and at some point you can maybe
see this pawn be picked off because
there's this pin going on f7 as well and
the Queen is also know there is the
possibility for the h-file to open up
the Queen and rook can one day be
functioning on an open H file and there
can be made soon on H a no good reason
to invite the Queen into your house like
this another factor that goes into
consideration that runs through my mind
here is that we have a case of opposite
sides castling so each side is really
looking to go after one another's throat
each side is looking to go after one
another's King and to invite the Queen
this deep into your territory not a good
idea something I'll kind of say to
myself here is well you know I'm gonna
keep this tension playing as black here
I'm gonna keep the tension and I'm not
inconvenienced by having my King as the
defender of the bishop
the Queen on the other hand you know she
probably she maybe wants to do something
other than babysit the bishop you know
it's I think in this position we can say
it's more of an inconvenience for white
to have the Queen as the defender of
this Bishop than it is to have the black
King as the defender of this bishop
moving on this one here tension between
the Queens would you chop okay no it's
not a good idea to initiate this capture
neither side is thrilled to have the
Queens where they are because the
bishops are not able to contribute can't
move and if you can't move the bishops
you can't you can't move the King side
bishops you can't go King side castles
so you may see in a position like this
both players be a bit stubborn where
neither player initiates the exchange
white plays Bishop b2 black maybe says
you know what I'm not going to take you
because you're just gonna recapture and
the bishop is improved so I'm in a
castle and we might have just this
little you know this little battle once
more where neither side wants to give
that inch okay not a good idea to
initiate the queening exchanges again
this is about an even ish position but
we're trying not to even give the
slightest bit to our opponent we have
our eye on the development part of the
game at least in this example we don't
want to help the bishops to develop
that's exactly what would happen for
both if you initiate the exchange the
bishop recaptures and is improved next
example what about this one here black
to move would you capture the Queen okay
I'm throwing this one in here because
it's a little bit
different
you a different thought process
first of all this is a winning position
for black this is not one of these one
of them this is not an example where the
position is about even black is winning
this black has a
an extra night black has a night black
is up a night versus pawn
now
objectively the best move is Queen to c7
so not initiating this exchange but
there are practical reasons why you
would want to do want to initiate this
exchange even though you're helping the
rook and the rook will soon be activated
by way of d7 if you calculate a little
bit deeper here eventually you'll know
as black you can negate this rooks
influence on the seventh rank
King coming over like this if the rook
goes here it's going to be stuck
I'm not sharing this example because I'm
pointing out you have to calculate a ton
in some positions I'm sharing this
example to let you know that sometimes
it's okay to give an inch like this
because you're you're ensuring something
you're you're ensuring in this case that
your King is not going to come under any
heavy fire you're trying to simplify a
position in you know you want to
simplify sometimes when you're up
material black is that material black
knows that yes I'm helping white out a
little bit but I'm not gonna have any
fear of my King coming under attack now
how might that spring about if let's say
the Queen went to c7 let's just play out
a few moves these aren't best moves but
I just want to give you a sense how you
know there could be a problem one day if
the Queen's are still around I wasn't
making best moves just there but my
point is that maybe it's sometimes okay
right to help to help out your
opponent's piece like this if you can
trade down some get rid of the most
powerful piece on the board this is
again in a position type where you're
still you still have an advantage as
black you're still up that material and
you can eventually negate this rooks
influence now the seventh rank
okay let's have a look at another one
black to move here would you chop okay
in this position there isn't a great way
for black to support the night
so I move like d5 there isn't enough
support for that
yeah there's just not enough support for
it White has two attackers on this
square Y can take and if there's this
recapture black and win the pawn if
after this capture now there is this
well keep in mind the bishop is now also
there to defend okay there isn't a great
way to defend the knight on d4 in this
position so black has some questions to
answer is it better to back off
bring the knight back to this square
well no not really because one of the
things black wants to be able to do in
this position is form a pawn duo get
this pawn up to e5 and if you're backing
off with the knight this guy can make
this move difficult right if you're
playing this move Y can take on persona
and yeah there's no pawn duo that white
has to worry about
here's the thing black cast away in this
position once white to me once black has
determined backing off is not a good
option the question is now which of
these two nights to capture which one is
better to take well if we apply that of
ranking thought process to this moment
we know that it is probably better to
knock out the third ranked Knight than
the second ranked night
one additional reason you may assign for
taking the knight on c3 instead of d2 is
well you know what I would much or I
would prefer to help out a tiny bit my
opponent's piece that is already
developed then to take a piece and have
my opponent recapture and develop a
piece connect the rooks like this
the better night to take in this case
and now black can follow up with e5 this
is as far as I want to go with this digs
it with this example which night to take
in this case how can you maybe reason
which which a decision is better okay
moving on black to move would you chop
okay hopefully no because the rook is
going to be improved what's a better
move Knight c5 I really like this move
not only because it is attacking the
Queen but black is now basically saying
AHA I have a 5th ranked night and you're
still working with a second ranked night
and on top of this your night on d2 is
obstructing the rooks view of this only
opened file
Knight c5 is a good choice sometimes
ducking this Knight exchange is useful
this is one of those moments
having a look at another one you what
about here white to move would you chop
no not a good idea here white has
further advanced center ponds and
because of this this can well this is
having an influence on this night here
it's not going to have too many great
squares to work with considering these
16 it's better for white to avoid the
night exchange play to move play to a
square like d3 or f3
I like d3 because it helps control two
of black's pawn breaks black may look to
challenge this Pandu on the knight from
d3 does a good job of fighting off these
two moves and again we can use this
reasoning well I have a third ranked
knight in this case who is in the key
sixteen squares of the board and you
have a second rank Knight that is
outside this key area
moving on and also I know another thing
it's not important like there is no you
know let me let me be clear here there
is no great follow up if white is
initiating the exchange it's not like Oh
Knight takes Knight check and after you
recapture I get to play the move no
there's not really any great follow up
here it's not important to have that
next move you could simply back off duck
that exchange in this case moving on
probably get the idea here at this
series of examples this little Knight
tension we have going on
would you chop hopefully no back off in
this case and say I have a fourth ranked
night and your night is still on the
edge and this night it seems like it
could be maintained for quite some time
on that c4 square not a great way to
scare them away this is a good this is a
good move avoid the exchange but the
night on nice square there isn't a great
follow up once more after Knight takes
Knight and a recapture no great follow
up for white better to maintain the
Knights in this case great square for
the knight on c3 tucking that Knight
right behind that pond is wonderful
there are also other options look every
every night move in this case has
support of the white pawns so these are
these are different things that factor
in you know something to my you know
that runs through my mind at least you
know Knight on c4 right behind a palm
that is established in white in a blacks
position it's very strong that's
configuration right here just these two
focusing on these two is very strong
let's have a look at another one black
to move would you chop
okay hopefully
well again these are even ish positions
it is not best to take on e3 I believe I
shared an example some other video
related to you know this this idea where
if you take you know you are doubling
the white pawns but at the same time
what has been influenced is this Zef
file and is now half open for the rook
doubled pawns rook activity this is this
is something for white
you know white is benefiting the rook is
benefiting what would be better you can
back off keep the tension you know
neither side has a
great file for the rooks this isn't
really a great file for a black rook to
go to because after b3 there's you're
not you're not breaking down the poem
that's on v3 it's rock-solid so there's
this battle going on in this position at
least over you know who who's going to
have an open file first you don't want
to just give your opponent an open file
when there aren't even any open files on
the board you're are productive I should
say open files for the rooks better to
back off in this case keep the tension
and it is important to back off in this
case you would not want to allow this to
happen not just because you're dropping
the pawn in this case but triple
isolated pawns you can't look at that
one for too long best is to back off in
this position maintain the tension and
follow-up question if white plays Bishop
takes Bishop
how do you recapture this guy or this
guy hopefully we chop here right gotta
get that piece backs okay so how would
you recapture a pawn or C pawn feel free
to pause the video
okay best here is to take towards the
center activate the rook these guys
still stay together actually it's just
one giant pawn island still of eight
even though there is an instance of
doubled pawns rook activity is really
nice to have here now you're gonna find
many players still want to do a move Oh
still wanna make a move excuse me still
want to make a move like C takes b6 and
there are plenty of cases where that
would be a good thing to do and I could
understand the reason you would want to
you know the reasoning you would have
for that you are what you are underling
your pawns you're straightening out your
pawns but the thing you're trying to
weigh here is black and this may you
know take some experience on your part
but what you're trying to weigh is is it
more important to have my pawns
straightened out or to give my rook some
nice activity in this case it's more
important to give this rook activity
okay moving on
light to move would you chop okay not a
good idea to take the bishop because
black can recapture taking with the palm
this rook is excuse me this file is now
completely open this pawn contributes
really well to the position though it
takes away what is normally a nice
improvement for the knight on f3
there is no 95 anymore and well what
would be better than taking the bishop
well similar to the last position you
can back off and say well you take me
and how would you recapture I'll just
give this one away
will you take towards the center rook
activity and we keep these pawns
together one pawn island of five
consecutive files this is a nice pond
Island a5 if you take like this well
they're split okay taking like this
would be the way and you can very easily
see black Oh wrong right if you're in a
position like this and you back off
right you don't take on d6 you back off
your opponent does take you take towards
the center your rook is active and you
may think well is that really a big deal
let's strike it white center well all of
a sudden you're gonna lose live like
Queen to d3 and this is just a quick way
we can see how this open file for the
rook is especially useful the night will
fall or the King will fall pick of
course black will not get mated but the
night will fall okay backing off is a
good idea in this case there is a way
that you can make use of the file and
another thing well let me just get into
the this desk example I'll get into this
other thing it's the same position a
couple of different moves have been
played castles now for why the rook has
moved over to ca what about this
position white to move would you chop
hopefully no because same story here the
pawn takes the rook is happy
there's no ninety five once more backing
off is a good idea and after Bishop
takes Bishop there should be no worry of
Bishop takes Bishop how would you
recapture with this guy or this guy now
that you're Castle okay it is once more
best to take towards the center keep
this pawn island a5
even though taking like this in this
case gives this rook an open file you
have to weigh is it worthwhile to have
these pawns split notice this is now a
hole this is now a hole this can
possibly be exploited at some point now
it is true black may have to defend some
along the F file all right we can see a
knight move and then all of a sudden
white is converging on f7 but it's more
important to not give up these these big
squares to the black side and it's more
important for white to not create these
unnecessary holes in White's position if
Knight to e5 is tried here there is a
simple defense to it f6
the knight has to go there is no you
know attack anymore on f7 so this kind
of pressure is short-lived
okay it is more important in this
position to keep these guys together
there are no great targets for black
alright there are no holes on e4 III
these are not considered holes okay
certainly the preferred recapture let's
have a look at another one black to move
here would you chop okay here we go
no not a good idea to take the bishop
for a couple reasons in this case we saw
one just a bit ago taking here not a
good idea because you're helping this
rook out but I have one more thing to
add in this case not only are you
helping this rook but you're helping
white
with this recapture to repair what was
to repair excuse me a hole on d4 let's
just go back at the moment this is the
weakest square in White's position and
initiating this capture is allowing
white to now take control over this d4
square d4 is no longer home the rook is
brought to life now in this case it is
not now what is better than capturing
the bishop first of all a better move is
to castle and even though white can
initiate this exchange and demote one of
these two pieces one of them is going to
have to recapture I guess we could just
have a look at which one we think might
be better here I'm going to say the rook
both is Adam both recaptures as a
demotion but it is the preferred choice
to allow one of the pieces to be demoted
than to have the rooks bring to life and
to have white repaired the d4 square
which of these two is better feel free
to pause the video I wasn't going to go
into this I didn't have it in my mind I
would cover this beforehand but yeah I'm
just seeing it now I would prefer to
take with the rook because the knight
we want to
keep it trained on this week and suika
Square in the position this rook whether
it's on a and Rh a there you see me a
eight or a seven neither is having an
impact on the center of the board
this guy is let's keep him around take
with the rook it's not like you're
losing castling privilege or anything by
capturing with the rook which was the
case a little bit earlier when there is
the the bishop tension I was pointing
out you were certainly wouldn't want to
take with the the King rook because you
couldn't Castle kingside it's a
different story here there's different
factors to take into consideration the
whole on d4 is a big one the file the F
file is a big one best not to take here
keep the tension get on with some
development okay let's have a look at
another one
okay black to move would you chop okay
hopefully no what's a better move than
capturing well first of all let's look
at why chopping is not a good idea
if you take white gets to take towards
the center and it's night now has a
great square on c3
what's the rush why take on deform what
would be better
what about knight c6
eventually this night's going to have to
move right let's say white castles
I mean we could keep the tension you
know it's this pond shouldn't be too
quick to budge eventually you know this
night is gonna have to move the White
Queen side cannot wait all day for the
c5 pond to initiate this exchange so
that way I can recapture and then go to
c3 the preferred development move for
that it's easier for what easier for
black to keep this tension it's not an
inconvenience for black to maintain the
tension so
when might black capture on d4 well
eventually the night is gonna have to
move if you just are a little bit
patient with this capture when the night
is on d2 ah now I'll think a little bit
more about capturing on d4 I may still
not capture at this moment but I'll
certainly wait playing as black here
I'll try my best to wait for this night
to go to a second-rank square instead of
you know opening up c3 so soon for the
night to go here so this is a little
battle that sometimes goes on with the
c5 pawn and you know playing from blacks
perspective the the c5 pawn and the b1
night and it could be reversed sometimes
you could see the c4 pawn putting
pressure on a d5 pawn and waiting for
the Queen Knight to go here now you
could have a black pawn supporting the
same thing just switched right there's
this little battle going on a little bit
of patience can have an impact on the
quality of the Queen Knight third ranked
9th second ranked Knight a little bit of
patience can go a long way okay oh
another thing about this position after
Knight c6 let's just say Knight takes
bishop how are we recapturing okay this
should look a little bit familiar to you
it's just on the other side of the board
it's on the Kings side in this case
instead of the Queen side once more we
take towards the center instead of
straightening out the pawns having this
rook activity is nice and even though
we're under pawns this is a little bit
of a I mean where's the black King gonna
be really safe the King is much more
vulnerable without this pawn on f7 it
must be said
if you could one day envision a major
piece getting to the seventh rank the
king is now cut off once your castled
you're cut off
there's no pawn shield this is excellent
in fact let me just go one step further
not only are you getting rook activity
as black you are opening up a wonderful
pocket for the black King the king is
going to fall in love with the g7 square
where we'll be shielded from
agonal checks one day rank checks file
checks and on top of it all very often
you'll find a king on g7 with this
little grouping here King on g7 instead
of on this back Square g8 if we ever one
day get into some kind of a pond race
you know white Queens black Queens well
when white as cleaning white is no
longer cleaning with check that's
another benefit of having the king on g7
instead of g8 now I'm throwing a lot of
stuff out there
it may seem Halle Rita you may be
questioning how realistic is that really
I'm just I'm speaking from experience so
the King on g7 with these three pawns
right here is
is a great asset for black okay it's a
good idea to take towards the center I
wasn't expecting to go into those
details with that example okay should
that capture have occurred once more
taking towards the center rook activity
and then some
let's have a look at another one
to move would you chop
let me be a bit more specific with this
example would you capture on d4
hopefully no similar reason is the last
example because you would be helping
this night to have a nice square now on
c3 another reason actually would be that
the knight can recapture and improve
slightly hit this hit this bishop
another thing is that it really isn't a
good idea to to take here yet at least
as the queen can recapture and improve
so in this position playing as black
what would I do I would get on with the
development I would know that after I
develop Knight to c6 I'm okay if you
take like this
I'm recapturing and improving I'm also
okay if you take like this because I'm
recapturing and improving so I'll keep
the tension in this case I think it's a
good idea to keep the tension in this
case and get on with development notice
in this case white can't make a move
make the move Knight d2 because you
would simply drop the bishop when may I
think a bit more about capturing the
bishop well let's say white says let's
say white says let's say white plays
Queen to d2 so that now Knight here is
available well maybe now I think a bit
more about capturing the bishop right at
least I'm at this point by delaying it
I'm saying AHA it took you two steps to
recapture because I was patient for just
a move okay
maybe still not best you could intensify
the pressure on d4 here Queen to b6
comes to mind
okay let's have a look at another one
mmm-hmm white to move here so would you
chop feel free to pause the video okay
once more just a reminder about the pons
and tension with one another which of
the two has more options is something I
look into the pond that's on d4 has more
options it can move forward it can
capture I don't think it's a good option
to capture on e5 it is not a good option
to capture here let me say that this is
a very common I don't know if I should
say mistake
yeah I'll say mistake it's not a good
it's not a good idea let me say that
it's not a good idea to make this
exchange here are the reasons why or
some of the reasons why for one after
chop and a reach op with the pawn what
pawns have just been exchanged I have a
fourth rank pawn exchange for a third
rank pawn
um you know puns they like to recapture
but that's not the only thing to factor
in here after this guy is recapturing
this guy's helped won two more options
and anything else influenced you bet
the knight has access to c5 there are a
lot of benefits for black with this
recapture the knight has helped the
bishop is helped as well drawing some
attention to the pawn on d4 one might
say it is doing a good job in
negating black from completing queenside
development before this bishop can move
the knight as to move before the rook
can move the bishop has to move it's all
starting with this night on d7 this pawn
is doing a very good job in controlling
the knight
it's not a good idea to take on e5
what's something different
y can do keep the tension I have more
options than you let's just support this
pawn Knight f3 is something that would
come to mind you could also consider
establishing a pawn in Black's house
upon on d5 in this case would be nice
even though you're giving up this Square
to the knight it's something to consider
certainly don't capture in this case
Knight f3 d5 different story support the
pawn maybe push the pawn but to have
this kind of exchange to help the bishop
to help the knight is not a wise choice
okay let's have a look at another one
this position here playing is black
would you chop okay earlier on I was
talking about pawn duo's this one here
White has a pawn trio this guy has more
options than this one it's important to
well break up pawn duo's and in this
case it's important to break up a pawn
trio this one that's in the center
usually is the more valuable or most
valuable of the three
if yeah it's important to take even
though this night is a is being helped
on the recapture if you don't capture on
d4 in this case let's say castles this
Bishop is going to have a very tough
time it can be absolutely shut out of
the game this is an absolute rock on d5
important to break up the pawn trio in
this case okay let's have a look at
another one hmm this may look familiar
in this position
[Music]
shared a position like this a while ago
now this videos going on for a bit we
had this exact position before with the
a pawns absent
okay anyhow light to move would you chop
the answer to that should be no it's
better to keep the tension something to
know about the ponds
puns like to take towards the center
rook pawns like to attack rip pawns like
to attack night pawns night pawns like
to attack Bishop pawns bishop pawns like
to attack center pawns in short pawns
like to chop towards the center again
those Center pawns are usually the more
valuable pawns when I see this position
I I II I think to myself the a pawn is
stronger than the b6 pun alright the the
a6 pawn has more options than the b6
poem
sure at any moment and open up the file
for the rook whereas black doesn't have
that available black doesn't have that
as a positive the ability in other words
to initiate the exchange and open up a
file when you want this is a great
benefit for white now at some point you
can capture maybe in some situations you
can also push and a push would normally
only be played if you can maybe one day
foresee that one of your pieces can have
access to the a7 pon because then that
pawn is going to be especially quick to
promote but the main point in this
particular example is to not initiate
the exchange keep the tension and well
what would be better than to initiate
the capture because if you do this again
we've already had this position where
the 8th the eight pawns just aren't on
the board and the rooks are in tension
and we know not to go forward with this
I suggested this with the king then
sneaking over in this position what
would be better
well first taking a step up rook to a4
let's just say a bit of a passing move
is played now now maybe it's a little
bit different now maybe Y can say I'll
take and then double up
and have control over the only open file
so something like this so with just a
little bit of patience we can have
putting on the white side some nice rook
activity or maybe even in this case just
keeping the rook here and keeping keep
black guessing is is why can a capture
on b6 is the a file going to open up
maybe the rook doesn't want to wait for
that the whole time and goes somewhere
else maybe at this point now you capture
and then sneak in and you have some nice
rook activities so there is some benefit
we're seeing in maintaining this tension
between the rook pawn and the knight
pawn let's have a look at another one
light to move here would you chop not a
good idea to chop I could have pointed
this out in the previous example
well I'll actually just go back for a
second after rook a4 if black is
capturing what you'll find now is that
this isolated pawn even though it is
passed is more so a liability than
anything you can be sure both rooks will
soon be trained on that point let me
actually just take it out a little bit
how my play develop something like this
and black is completely tied down to
defending this pawn
it's not fun this rook can't move as
soon as it moves this pawn or fall okay
there's value and maintain this tension
right here you get to decide as y in
this position when the file opens up
don't be too quick to initiate the
exchange they're white to move here
would you chop not really a good idea to
chop similar reason this guy is now
isolated and can come under some really
heavy fire what is better
um it's a bit tricky
I'd say well let's push and that way I
don't have to worry anymore about this
tension or x2 me about this tension
after worry about oh is the a file gonna
open up right now when we've later two
moves later I'll just play b4 well there
can sometimes be a drawback and there is
a drawback in this case this is in this
position right here
b4 can be met with a three
and this is
creating well how to say this exactly
with a black pawn on a3 a black pot on
a3 is making the white pawns disjointed
they're not able you know white wants to
be able to play a3 and have this pond
defended this can now maybe be struck
out moreover this pond is now fixed this
white pond is now fixed on a2 and is
accessible to maybe one day a black rook
or certainly this light square bishop
it's a bit uncomfortable for white this
pawn this black pawn on a3 has great
value it is uncomfortable quite often if
the rook pawn is able to engage with the
knight pawn like this we'll see how we
can address this problem in a little bit
just have a couple more examples first
moving on to this one here white to move
would you chop okay the answer to this
is hopefully no
shading this exchange well first of all
the best you know let me let me cover
this first capturing why is that not
good well it's not good because black
can take away from the center and the
primary reason for taking away from the
center here is not because oh I have an
open file for the rook look at all these
wonderful possibilities over here
there's one key possibility there's one
new move available black really needs
and that is the rook f7 move why is that
insult why is that so important well
after rook h1 this is the only defensive
move black has against h7 fending off
checkmate with a little bit of patience
here with this rook pawn playing here
first now what does black do there's no
good solution here let me just make just
a nothing move this is going to lead to
checkmate right
white is crashing through on h7 by
capturing too soon
white is allowing black to have this
defensive resource white has opened up
too soon
seventh ranked defense keep
tension in this case is best rook each
one and now the threat to take and then
smash through h7
will be decisive so just to point out
let's just make a a passing move or
excuse me let's actually just
if you capture White's taking like this
in the same story the King is going down
soon
suppose you give up a pond like this
this will also be trouble because of
these moves check check and eventually
we're gonna give me okay
the idea here maintaining the tension is
going to result in a win for white
releasing the tension too soon and it is
black who is actually preferred here
believe it or not perfect defense with
the rook here this night is not a
contributor to attack the king and this
is coming very fast so I'm opening up of
let's say the a file to get after the
king okay keep the tension in this case
question what pieces are influenced if
I'm making this exchange the rook is
certainly influenced let's have a look
at another one white to move would you
chop okay this should also be a no some
I guess some extra credit points for
those of you who are already familiar or
for those of you that can share what
game
this position is from it's a popular one
I have covered it on my channel ok
capturing too soon will allow black to
in this case take towards the center
taking break soon me take away from the
center taking towards the center not
always a good option certainly not here
checkmate but taking away from the
center in this case allow some defense
of h7 the winning move is queen h6 and
just to highlight why well now we get to
well after Queen h6 what is best how do
you actually defend this now after Queen
to f8 this is the sequence
pop quiz white to move what would you do
okay this is just a fun one to share we
would have the move clean takes h7 on
takes g6 double check the King goes back
it's checkmate and if the King takes
here that's checkmate
and this is only possible if as y-you
maintain the tension taking here first
and then playing here what are you even
threatening rook is defending both move
order patience with the pawns retain the
tension in this case okay let's have a
look at another one so
we'd understand hopefully by now that a
rip on simply engaging with a knight
pawn is usually seen as an asset I would
say so when it gets to a point such as
this and move like a four you may want
to make a move that doesn't even allow
that tension so what move would do that
in this position playing is black how
can you address the move a four you're
ready here we go
a five no more a a five possibility no
more possible tension a five is a good
move here for black moving on black to
play in this position
how would you address the move a for in
this position feel free to pause the
video okay here we go
a5 here not best so I want to show you a
difference here between the a5 and a6
moves if you play a5 the great downside
with that is that the night at some
point can play to b5 and that can be a
great bother to the black position
this pawn on c5 is not always going to
want to fulfill a role of stopping a
knight b5 move this this pond has dreams
of one day challenging White's pawn duo
in the center and you'll note that if
black it plays a move like c5 this will
now be a forever whole on b5 this will
be an inconvenience for black if this is
now a hole on b5 so what should you do
in reply to a for a better move is a six
and the idea here is to meet the move a5
with quickly resolving this tension b5
notice this position here there is not
the possibility to play a six for one
you know black could maybe even take
with the two minor pieces but if you
could just envision that the night is
over here on d6 and then this guy is
still back here pushing here is just not
available anymore right we have a pond
that is on
a six there is no a six by white these
pawns are not disjointed and there is
most importantly I feel at least no
longer this tension White has with the
rook pawn and the Knight pawn it has
quickly been resolved
that is important to have a look at
another one looking on the other wing
the kingside in this case black to move
how would you address the h4 move okay
here we go a good move here is it's
going to be one of these two which is
better similar to the last example h6 if
you play h5 it's true the pawn can't
engage with this pawn but you're giving
up a huge square to not only the knight
in this case but also the bishop so
better is play h6 preparing to meet a
and actually h5 with g5 not giving this
rook an opportunity to play along the
h-file not allowing the H file to open
up on White's terms and not allowing
this pawn to go deeper into blacks house
establishing upon on the sixth rank can
be quite good okay another pop quiz here
white to move would you chop on f5 feel
free to pause the video okay it is a
good choice to capture the bishop I'm
not going to go into any great details
with this one the idea here is to pull
the night away normally we would see
this as a a positive right the knight is
it is true has been improved but you'll
notice the follow up white is now able
to do what create this tension this is a
positive rip on attacking the knight
pawn
there is a there is a follow up that
white has in mind in this case so even
though the night is improved well we get
to initiate this tension which is a
positive as well it's the only thing I
really wanted to highlight with this
position right here
moving on black to move so a couple
different ways you can capture on B form
would you chop and if so with which pawn
okay here we go
not a good idea to capture with either
pun because this rook will be helped so
what do you do you keep the tension you
put yourself in a position to recapture
on c5 with the pond
or on a five probably have your pick at
this point the night or the pond could
be quite good
another thing to note actually with this
one is that not only are you helping the
rook by initiating the capture you're
giving up a new square to this knight
who may now look to circle in to a hole
in blacks position on b5 forgiving
enough giving up a nice square to this
night possibly who is at the moment a
struggling piece this is probably one of
the worst pieces for y in this position
I don't know how great this Bishop is
either this pawn that's on d4 is having
a great impact on the quality of these
two minor pieces okay short story not a
good idea to capture maintain the
tension be in a position to recapture
another example how many more do I have
about 10 are you still with me
you got great patience if you do give
yourself a pat on the back might be set
in a record with this video I don't know
what the clock time is that yet anyhow
white to move here
would you chop okay here we go
so these are getting a little bit more
involved
neither capture is good just like the
last example neither capture is good I
want to
point out a different move that's
available instead of initiating these
exchanges for one year
you're giving up a fourth rank pawn for
what is a third rank pawn this is
something that weighs into my thinking
there's more to it than that but instead
of instead of capturing on this square
something you can strongly consider
playing as white is the following move
g5 and you see what just happened there
what is this g5 pawn doing actually
maybe the better question is what is the
g5 move not doing exaggerating a little
bit when I say it like this the g5 move
is taking away the f6 Square from one
night two nights a bishop of rook a
queen this pawn on g5 is having a great
cramping effect on the black pieces it
is influencing the quality of three
minor pieces and a couple of major
pieces
and white is also setting up to one day
create this tension with the rook pawn
attacking the knight Fon this may ensure
that though the white rook will be able
to create an open file straight towards
the black King by passing this tension
taking a moment here to control the f6
square this is a great post for that
pawn ok main thing here is initiating
the capture not best g5 is a wonderful
move not the only strong move this is
also good as well but g5 certainly has
its points just a killer pawn
okay let's have a look at another one
here white to move I don't have an arrow
drawn out on this one would you chop on
f6 feel free to pause the video okay
it's not best to take on f6 I'll just
say first of all that one of the better
moves the computer points out is King to
be one I'm not going to get into the
reasons why that is the move I want to
point out a different idea one can have
you know this is a positional topic here
we're trying to look at what pieces are
influenced when we initiate the capture
if we're initiating the capture on f6
you'll note that okay the knight can
recapture the bishop can recapture the
rook is now active you can also start to
consider pawn sacrifices I'm only going
to show I think it's just this one and
maybe one other example yeah there's
this idea where you can give up a pond
okay this is getting a little bit deeper
this is this is a deeper ID in the game
but recognizing in this position is why
you know what if I take here I'm
bringing a lot of the black pieces to
life I'm gonna give up a pond and even
though it could be captured like this
I'll have some security for my queen
you know this file is not going to open
up this square is not going to be
available to the minor pieces and I can
now try to as white pursue an attack
against the king we are castled on
opposite sides
material shouldn't be that big of a
factor giving up just a pawn maybe in
this case it is one of the better ideas
for white to actually go for what's
known as a positional pawn sack and
again this is this is a little bit of a
deeper ID in the game but it has to do
with diminishing the the the quality of
your opponent's pieces now to activating
your pieces your opponent's pieces
excuse me and that's exactly what would
spring about if white is initiating this
exchange on f6 okay
another example here this is this is a
fun little battle you can i I I think
I've had yeah I've had first-hand
experience with this this move sequence
before probably have probably multiple
times just want to point out this these
positional ideas in action in this
position
black is a bit
comfortable because of this tension
white has white can take at any moment
and you know on White's terms open up
the a file so what is what can black do
here well black can play the move b4
okay and at first glance it's like well
isn't isn't white just winning upon well
let's see let's say after white takes so
this isn't really some pop quiz I just
want to share some of my thoughts about
the the following moves after C takes B
form this rook comes over and attacks
the palm and now black is gearing up to
do what ready to take this pawn and have
a great rook position be targeting both
white pawns in white right now is up
upon and does not want black to have
this kind of activity for the rooks
so what does black do activate the rook
no white says I'm gonna give the pawn
back and after you capture it I'm not
going to take here
taking here will allow rook takes rook
rook takes rook and black will emerge
with a very active rook even though the
pawn is passed is it a liability is it
an asset it's a long way off from posing
a threat to black white has to go on the
defensive and has to tend to this rook
takes B to threat so what can white do
instead of capturing here again showing
the sequence d4 take before chopped rook
b8 b5 chopped and we don't take here but
instead sneak by with a5 neither side is
this is this is a the computer's eyes an
equalist position but I just wanted to
show you a sequence of pawn moves rook
moves where we have this little
positional battle each side trying to
activate the rooks you know black
initially gives up upon with b4 hoping
that the rook can take here and have
this wonderful activity right this is
this is exactly what black would have if
they were able to capture on b4 this is
a fantastic piece sitting three white
pawns but you know give up upon you're
trying to get this activity for the rook
white recognizes that gives the pawn
right back
doesn't take pushes here it gets a
passed pawn it's a nice little battle
that went on right there and taking it a
step further you may see that black
tries to make sure these pawns cannot
support one another the b-pawn can't
support the pawn and then
well I can try to target this guy but
the main point here is that there's
these little positional ideas that go on
it involves
activity in this case a little bit of
pond play being prepared to give some
material back in order to not allow your
opponent to activate one of their pieces
okay let's have a look at another one
Queen
tension this kind of looks a bit similar
to I think what is it the first example
I threw your way in this video okay
white to move would you chop okay uh it
is actually a good idea to take the
Queen here may be surprising to some to
to hear that taking the Queen I feel is
a one of the best moves here even though
this rook is improved and in order to
understand why that's a good option for
white is well there's some some factors
to take into consideration for sure if
you don't take the Queen let's say you
play Queen to see - I would just like to
point out that the black queen
this c7 square is fantastic a black
Queen on c7
is a full queen queen is a multi-purpose
piece and the black Queen from c7 is
certainly fulfilling many tasks these
two pawns are isolated and conveniently
defended by the Queen the queen is also
observing 'if I've which is a square the
knight would like to go to one day so
it's making a 95 more difficult a 95
move more difficult and if you want to
maybe go one step further you can say
the Queen from c7 is eyeing up h2 which
is I believe the likely flight square
for white
light would not like to play g3 and
create some light square weaknesses
create holes on the kingside this is the
flight square the queen not only
controls the 95 move but maybe one day
be there to take away this safe
this flight square from the king so
maybe there's more stuff those are the
things that spring to mind for me the
queen would be wonderful from c7
defending the isolated pawns ePHI of h2
best is to actually exchange the Queens
maybe it is now a bit easier to target
these isolated pawns maybe it is a bit
more ease a bit easier to play to
improve the 995 is available
it's tricky sometimes you have to see
beyond just this simple recapture all
the rooks improved
let's not exchange Queens it's a lot
more we can be factoring in this these
are some I get these are some deeper
ideas there's more that goes into it
okay let's have a look at another one
black to move would you chop okay
actually it is it is an okay idea to
chop the bishop in this case this is
when I shared a bit ago and I said it
was not a good idea but you'll notice
that this position is a bit different
from the other one and the other one we
had a case of opposite sides castling
that is not the case here
taking the bishop in this case we are
bringing the Queen in deep into our
position but unlike that other position
again not opposite sides castling here
and there is not another white piece
that I can see interacting well with the
Queen in this in this area there is no
good there is no good white piece that
will help
and coordinate with the white queen and
by initiating this exchange one of the
what does black gain black gains a nice
check within a follow-up b4 move
there is no this queen is kind of out of
play in a way if she cannot be connected
with some other white piece it may just
be the case that she's out of play now
this has to be weighed very carefully
you know if she is after all taking away
a flight square that is true but you
know
there's some there's some activity for
the black pieces there are these
queenside ponds that are coming under
some fire
it appears that yeah it's going to be
quite difficult to to be defending the
c2 square or the c2 pond or at least an
inconvenience let's say to the white
side here's actually something I'm
noticing right now trying to defend c2
like this first of all to have to back
up like this disconnect the rooks is
gonna be a problem this is just one
quick variation this is looking pretty
dangerous all of a sudden the knight
sweeping in with check who knows maybe
there's a smothered mate nearby okay
sometimes I think in most cases this
would be rare to invite the Queen into
the position but I guess what I'm
getting at is uh you know there are
these exceptions sometimes maybe it is
okay to bring the Queen in there's a be
a bit more delicate but you know this is
this is one of those cases where it is
actually okay to do that most cases
probably not a good idea this is an
exception so have a look at another one
like to move would you chop feel free to
pause the video okay this one is not
well I shared this earlier this Bishop
for Knight exchange and I said well not
really a good idea because I was able to
just recapture the knight is improved
but White has an idea in mind this is a
much more dynamic position again
primarily in this video we were
concerned with even ish positions white
or black slightly better white is
looking to pursue an attack the King is
still in the center white is trying to
get at it even though the knight is
improved this Knight is now out of the
way there's these follow-up ideas of a
check and another check like this
if you know the night just backs off to
block white is looking to attack the
king so you know to see a little bit
deeper here to take yeah I'm improving
the night but now I have ways to get at
the King it's a bit more the King is a
bit more accessible okay so in this case
that is actually a best move to take the
night
what about here black to move how many
more examples do I have not a lot just a
few more you still with me okay black to
move would you chop okay is this an
improvement for the night
alright the night is moving backwards is
an improvement I think it is an
improvement but you could still see a
move like this played
whatwhy wakes to me what black wants to
do and in this position the knight on e4
is very strong and white and extremely
black would like to control the e4
square with upon like to scare that
night away but this Bishop is not going
to really enjoy this environment this is
now this is a bad bishop it is actually
a good idea to give up a bishop for not
in this case and after the knight
recaptures too then
play d5 and next c5 this is a good way
forward for black to recognize this is a
locked position the Knights will be a
little bit better in this environment
many instances of fixed pawns the
Knights can navigate this position well
important to note that you are giving up
your bad bishop for the knight in this
case and then looking forward yeah bad
bishop for the night you're giving up
then controlling this square getting rid
of this wonderful square from the knight
right behind that pond and following up
with c5 this is a good way forward for
black this is a fine exchange considered
one of the better options for black in
this position
okay another example here night tension
I believe this is one of the one of the
last examples I have for you yes
and if I'm not mistaken this position
comes from a game played between
stockfish on the white side and Leela
chess is zero not a hundred percent of
that I'm pretty sure anyhow
when you look at this position with an
engine the suggestion well I'm using
stockfish 10 right now and with limited
time giving the engine to think this
position through its not coming up with
the move Lila played and I tend to agree
more so with other moves Lila is is
playing in this position so anyhow first
of all would you chop on b3 feel free to
pause the video would you play Knight
takes Knight okay it's not a good idea
to take the knight first of all white
will benefit by taking that with the
Queen but with the pond I can this a
rook activity even though there is this
doubling of the pawns
this is this is useful for white so what
move would you play here the stockfish
10 right now is suggesting an 8 h6 move
is one of the moves suggested but the
move Lila played
I tried to then assign reasons for why
that move was played so I'm just gonna
put the move on that was played by Lila
this night went back and I know I shared
some examples where you know you you you
duck a night exchange and you say aha my
night is better than your night this
one's a bit counterintuitive I think
there's some deeper reasoning that needs
to be used or you need to have a deeper
understanding of this position to know
maybe why ninety seven is one of the
better moves and you know even though
the night is a second-rank night and
this is a third-ranked night why is this
may be a good retreat move in this case
again these are I think at least some
some some deeper ideas you would have to
use to understand this move but here's
how I think it through this pawn on f5
is not a pond that will be challenged
it's going to be around for some time
you're not going to get playing as black
here you're not going to get rid of this
pond and one thing playing is black you
would not like to see is this pond being
established on f6 and
approach white maybe able to take is to
try and eliminate a piece that is
getting in the way of this pawns advance
right if this pond could get here and
control this square White has dreams of
giving checkmate with the Queen a white
pond can be very cramping on f6 I think
dropping the knight back is helping
black to maintain a piece and not just
any piece on f6 but to mate to be able
to maintain a knight on f6 that really
is not an inconvenience for black if it
is a bishop who has to recapture we can
say that that Bishop is primarily a
defensive piece and that's it actually
specifically a defensive piece that
stares at its own pawns it really does
not fulfill a productive role whereas a
knight does a knight will stop the pawn
from moving forward and also exert
pressure on a white pawn that will
require the support of white pieces now
I know I'm going this is this is quite
involved and this is quite different
from this this position right here is
quite different from the first position
I shared in this video but I'm not a
hundred percent sure of the reasoning
I'm using here these these moments in
the game are without question difficult
I don't have all the answers I'm just
I'm trying to help set you and I'm
trying to help you have the correct
frame of mind to help you to try and
think critically about this game there's
there's a lot going on here with with
the move Knight to d7 in my opinion and
I think again it's related to ensuring a
knight is always going to be around on
that f6 Square even though it is this
you know second-ranked Knight versus
third-ranked Knight battle okay how many
more examples do I have not much just
two more examples that in fact this next
one here I was saying I have a couple
games I want to share with you just a
few moves deep this is one of them
happened not to not too long ago 227
yeah let's just say 2700 feet a players
maybe even a little bit higher
I just want to show you how a game plays
out where tension is maintained and you
could be sure that when these guys are
playing again they don't neither player
wants to give an inch so let's see the
different moves that are played here
white on move plays rook to c1 the white
clearly doesn't want to take here and
help the knight
improve I up the c5 square so what do
you do instead
Brooke c1
when is black due Queen d7 still the
tension is maintained castles tension is
still there rook c8 applying pressure
here saying no you take me and here's
the here's a fun move this one made me
laugh white doesn't want to help this
Knight so much it actually drops back to
e2 and says no I don't want your knight
to go to a six in fact that's the only
good square the knight has right they
can't go to d7 can't go to c6 so this
tension is still present Queen b7 so
when I was fishing for some what I felt
are nice examples for this this topic
this video this is one of the games I
cycled her and I thought wow that's
that's pretty neat you were seeing this
right in action this is ID to maintain
the tension for so many moves now it's
still there efore was played Knight B to
d7 when is it going to break when is the
tension going to be released only after
this move right here after b4 and there
is now this threat to play b5 finally do
we have the tension resolved and why can
just say AHA I have benefited just a
little bit on this recapture this is
still a great struggle don't get me
wrong I just wanted to highlight the
tension in the position how it could
just linger there for many many moves at
these high levels neither player wants
to give an inch one more example where
it carries on for 25 moves Bishop c4
this tension between the pawns is
present for forever and here's here's an
interesting note this this tension
between the bishops and Bishop and
Knight is only released after this
Bishop has moved so I was sharing
earlier about tension between a the pawn
on c5 and upon on d4 and only capturing
after the Knight has played here that
way I can't make use of c3 we have
something a little similar going on here
with the bishop and knight the bishop
doesn't want to take the knight until
this Bishop has moved from d7 because
after now Knight c3 White knows that the
bishops going to have to take another
step to defend this pawn so maintaining
the tension it's worth noting that you
know if this capture is played I was
thinking that white is now going to
recapture with a piece you know a knight
in particular but that's not considered
best considered best I believe in every
case is a white recapturing with the
pawn which is allowing the rook to
spring to life and white to coordinate
on the d5 square but my point here is
that well I found it quite interesting
that this tension
his tension between the two pawns was
present for 25 moves are 25 half moves
25 white and black moves and when does
it release only at this point so we go
quite quite deep in the game was it 25
moves
yeah about about 25 moves it was white
and black was and after it was resolved
anyhow only at this point did we have
these uh mass exchanges which is you
know it's okay this position is not of
interest to me at least anymore but yeah
interesting to see this tension linger
in a position for so long and especially
at these higher levels there's this
tendency the you know the lower the
lower level player you are you're more
inclined it seems at least that's just
from my experience that there's this
quick idea - well it's just let's just
exchange pieces let's just go with these
this even exchange there are no even
exchanges right okay anyhow last two
examples for the most part I've been
showing you opening examples middle game
examples and well here we are now again
with this mentality of you know I don't
want to capture and allow my opponent to
recapture and improve that piece well we
can see it in much more simplified
positions and sometimes it could mean
the difference between drawing and
winning in this position here what would
give me pause with rook takes rook well
I know that the black King will be able
to recapture and improve and sure enough
this position here will go on to be a a
drawn position what is the winning move
well the winning move is to first say
check you have to block and only now
will I take because after you recapture
you went sideways if not forward and
this is enabling white to now establish
a wonderful King position as 6th ranked
King versus a first rank king and a king
that is ready to quickly hunt the Queen
side pawns and if black wants to stop
that well there are these little tricks
here deflecting the defender of f6 and
what do we have here well this pawn on
g2 controls you know the g2 pong
controls these two and white basically
has an extra pawn white will go on to
win this white as a passer winning for
white better King position and a upon
that's ready to roll
final example getting right down to the
very basic endgame an interesting one
here whoo-hoo it whoever excuse me is on
move in this position if that side
initiates the capture you lose
so light in this position if you capture
black will recapture have opposition and
you go this way I go this way and this
pawn will be hunted there'll be some
little pawn race and black will go on to
win so let me just I'll play it out some
you could just see that white is not
even close to getting a queen black
would be much too fast here black will
go on to win so what is the winning way
well it's recognizing we don't want to
take because black can recapture and
improve the king
so King to d4 apply pressure to this
pawn forced you to take me and now I get
to recapture I have opposition at this
point and white in this case will go on
to win
so I don't have any more examples I'm
gonna take a peek at what the video is
saying oh yeah this is a record I
believe for this uh this playlist I
think at least approaching three hours
are you still with me you're crazy if
you've been with me for the three plus
hours straight do I have anything more
to add
um I don't think so these are subtle
points but yeah we don't want to give it
up give up an inch it those inches add
up and you kind of want to have this you
know position before submission
mentality you know these I know there's
this great draw to tactic cinch in chest
smothered mates all what a combination
but these decisions that lead up to
those to those moments you know these is
these these technical points these
subtle points being a good decision
maker in these decision and they'll
excuse me these these technical moments
help maybe set you up to one day being a
in a great position for a tactic it's
rare that you're going to see tactics
spring about from
in inferior position right I believe
that what's what's the quote by Bobby
Fischer tactics flow from a superior
position right have this position before
submission mentality and to stop before
you chop is really the main thing here
do I have anything more to add I don't
think so this has gone on long enough
and I hope you know sharing these
positional factors is going to be
helpful for you to you know be a bitter
bitter don't be better to be a better
decision maker when you play and
hopefully you found this video
beneficial so that's all for this one
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
in the comments section below I hope you
enjoyed it and we'll see when video 29
comes out that's all for now take care
bye
you